now i mentioned up top that uh of course
you've got the the music career going
tenacious d yeah and then you've got
this movie career going yeah what do you
prefer what's your true love
you're asking me
to make sophie's
did you choice the movie sophie's choice
yeah i don't think she was choosing
between being around
they're my children
and uh they're equally tremendous one of
them
gives me unlimited wealth
and the other one gives me a tremendous
fiery passion i won't choose
i won't choose that was very brave of
you not to choose you have a lot of uh
integrity i think as a performer thank
you kind sir uh it's conan
you're doing this movie uh with uh
gwyneth paltrow big movie star did you
like working with her oh yeah you guys
have a nice connection there she's you
know she's amazing i mean i was nervous
at first
because you know she's got a lot of
prizes and stuff
and then
but when we got when we got to the
series
yeah
the fairley's the fairly brothers
directed and wrote the the picture and
they said when gwyneth gets here just
just pretend like you're the worst actor
in the history of the world just just go
crazy over the top ham and cheese
and for the rehearsal and i said all
right that's that's a good idea that's
gonna be funny so she got there and we
started the rehearsal and i was just ah
no
and then she was kind of sweating a
little bit and
she but she kept on going like a pro
just doing the lines the way she wanted
and then
and then uh we got to the end and the
fair ladies were like cut oh amazing
jack just so good
and i saw her eyes were darting around
like what
what and i said no i'm just kidding i'm
not gonna do it like that until he goes
oh thank god
okay yeah let's just do it you know
with the real real deal now and um then
we did it i did my best acting and then
she was really scared
and the fairlies were like
can you do a little more of the stuff
you did in the first day
but then i relaxed and i cranked out a
masterpiece i mean
a lot of people
thank you
a lot of people saying
i'm truly adorable really wow truly
adorable that's what they're saying for
me to say yeah yeah now how was your but
life's good for you right now right it's
yeah it's got to be things are things
are moving along at breakneck speed i
mean
the truth is i'm just constantly
stressed off stage i can't i can't like
have any peace at all and
really i'm only relaxed like when i'm
out here with you and it's like jordan
you know on the court
and i felt like
like michael jordan's only relaxed when
he's with me but he you know what i'm
talking about the razzmatazz of the
business is insane in fact i can i got a
clip from backstage just to give you a
taste of it can we shift his like right
now yeah sure from backstage yeah let's
show this in my dressing room fine
whatever bottom line is you got to do
this movie no i never said i would do it
you made a commitment i made there was
no commitment what are you talking about
you shook the guy's hand you gave him a
power handshake no you got to do the no
no i no i never squeezed okay i gave him
a limp hand he squeezed no commitment
all right fine whatever bottom line is
you got to do three movies you got to do
poops mcgee one two and three you're the
lead you're poops mcgee no i'm not
troopsman
flash drops flash drops
all right guys mr black hi your visitor
is here yeah just a second listen you
tell them there's no hands down he wants
your autograph just a second i'm dealing
with something okay now you tell him
watch your autograph as agreed
god get out of here
you are not in my world if i don't get
anything from you i don't talk to you to
go
monster
what
i think i'm a monster
monster
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's
mr black
you're on now
let's rock
wow
that was riveting
that's just the taste conan
just a taste of what it's like the world
that we live in you and i
the non-stop razza matas
please don't start crying again that was
too horrifying are you you're making
good money now you're making the big
scratch that's what i like to call it oh
come on you're making movies
that everybody knows it though yeah
because then it's like you ever see the
movie ransom yeah they'll smuggle me
and they when they'll get the money yeah
and then they won't give me back alive
the chop off my head and stuff me in a
hole
that's a pleasant thought i mean
basically my life is the same except i
live in the same shack but i build a big
wall around it
and a guy i bought a robot to protect me
i had it designed you had a robot design
it's a human-shaped robot i designed it
after shack o'neil
and and he has laser vision
and
no one's bi
you're just lying to me now it's true
it's all true you know it's you last
time you were here which is just a
couple of weeks ago yeah it's been it's
not been long enough it has not been
long enough
you were here with your your partner
kyle yeah and you guys you guys sang a
number yeah and i was thinking you know
as happy as i am to see you it's too bad
he's not here because then you could you
guys could do a number five i could i
could break off for solo you want to
button up
all right i do a really good seal you do
a what the seal
you do you do see there's so much a man
can tell you so much he can say
you
remain
my power my pleasure my pain
and that's really
it wow
seal doesn't do all that though
no seal would be a bigger star if he
acted it out the way you do it's true
maybe we can work together
it'll be my new partner no cage shreds i
shouldn't have even busted off that
without cage yeah he did the right thing
though well shallow hal opens this
friday this is gonna be a big movie
you've went with paltrow you've arrived
my friend thank you kind sir thank you
very much for being here too always nice
to have you here jack jack
you